دي منطقه سيدي حسين جنوب العاصمه التونسيه
التقينا عادل الجامعي احد المترشحين
للانتخابات التشريعيه الذي شرعا في القيام
بحملته عبر وضع برنامجها الانتخابي في
المكان المخصص له ولقاء اهالي المنطقه
الاقناعبين منهم بالتصويت لفائدته
اول ايام الحمله بدا باهتا حتى ان اغلب
المترشحين لم ينطلق بعده في حملته لدي
عديد للمشاكل اللي مش نستخدم عليها بما
فيها من نقل الي الحمد لله معناتها
الاعداد بتاع الكيران غير كيف هي الاعداد
بتاعت التكسيات تغير كيف ولا بد من زياده
خطوط كذلك المصاب برج شكير اللي يسمى
المراقبه هو غير المراقبه انت نقول الحمله
التي لم يقتصر على المترشحين فقط بل شمله
ايضا منظمات المجتمع المدني جمعيه بدات
عملها منذ ثلاثه اشهر ونشرت اكثر من ثلاث
مئه ملاحظ في مختلف الدوائر التي غبيه
وكانت هذه حصيله مخالفات اليوم الاول
وخاصه من بعض المترشحين لنشاطات في حين
لما اتصل للمنسق الجهوي بتاعنا بالهيئه
الفرعيه الهيئه الفرعيه لم تكن على علم
بالنشاط هذه بدايه الخروقات في اليوم
الاول الحمله الانتخابيه
هيئه الانتخابات تؤكد انها اتمت
استعداداتها البشريه واللوجستيه لاجراء
الانتخابات رغم التشكيك في سلامه المسار
واطلقت واحده ميدانيه لرصد الحمله
الانتخابيه على وسائل الاتصال السمعيه
البصريه
الجديد هي الوحده
تم احداثها بمقتدى القناه التركيب الجديده
عدد 31 لسنه 2020 وهي وحده رصد الحمله
الانتخابيه في وسائل الاتصال البصري
معناها في القنوات
بالداخل الى الخامس عشر من الشهر القادم
قبل يوم الصمت الانتخابيه وسط جده لان حاد
فرضته طبيعه الظرف السياسيه الاستثنائيه
للحمله الانتخابيه في الداخل والانقسام
بشانها لان المراقبين يعتبرون انها ستكون
ساخنه نظرا لتبيعه الاستحقاق التشريعيه
ودوره في ناحيه ملامح المشهد السياسي
القادم بتاع اعتباره اخر المحطات على درب
تاسيس الجمهوريه الجديده وليد عبد الله
العربيه
تونس